[Applause]
you know yellow it up see that video
I'll just sent you that nice swishah
Willis
that kid is shoot thing on my news about
they check him up I'm an I'm an i we
bout to make this kid's day see when we
stop and I were real quick now you hear
what I was saying
dedication out here in the middle of
Iowa cornfield or cornfield on cornfield
as the home of Shoshone with a natural
athlete born with only one arm he went
viral for Duncan Utley and he plays QB
don't tell him he's disabled and do not
call him special he's only a sophomore
in high school and this kids just
getting started
the first one that got caught on camera
was at the middle school it was like the
fourth quarter and I stole it and then I
dunked it and then you just see the
student section going crazy so I just
asked Dean of Students for the security
footage and then I screen recorded it
and post it on Twitter hey boys just
like just I don't know I just blew up
all my friends were like boosting me up
and stuff and saying like oh you're
famous blah blah blah it's just natural
to me to just go out and do my best and
I guess that just amazes people because
I do have
tre'sean was born with amniotic band
syndrome which is a band in your
amniotic fluid that wraps around
something that's developing you go
through a hundred different emotions of
how is my child gonna survive with one
arm but there was nothing that he
couldn't do or learn how to do he was
able to learn it right a bike zip and
button his pants so winter Shaun's dunk
went viral I guess it didn't really
surprise me that he could dunk a
basketball for us to put limitations on
trishaw clearly isn't fair me he's still
a big six four body kid with incredibly
strong lower body that it's got a great
vertical jump you know they're playing
with one hand he's dominating there's
times last year I couldn't take him off
the court she was the best player on our
team he's really good with his outside
shot my jump shot I think it's normal so
I just take my hand and put on the back
and then I use my little arm to make
sure it doesn't like fall off so that's
just what I do
only adjustments I'd say are like
dribbling most heaters try and force me
to go to my left he's got like this kind
of goofy Euro step that he uses he can't
cross over and he just can't do it so he
has a mover he just goes behind his back
and then catches it on the left side it
was times when he was constantly getting
the ball stolen from he's trying to
figure it out and figure it out and he
just couldn't he could just couldn't
figure it out if he just made that one
little turn and turned like this with
the ball he just started working it out
kids come at him kids kids really don't
care that they're competitive as well
you know you know they're getting scored
on by a kid that only has one arm they
don't like it one game last year some
kid
guy swatted them and went out of the
bounds I said get that out of here he's
like sure dopey we really have one arm
so that just sent me off I went off on
him he never comes to me and say that I
can't get through this yeah he admit
that stuff is hard you know but he never
said that he can't usually people that
got some kind of you know we give him a
pass on I can't
because we have compassion for them but
I can't with my son look for victory to
sweet you know your friends keep coming
up to me said he want you to they want
to still see you at quarterback
[Music]
her son is our varsity starting middle
linebacker number two backup QB he's
really the leader in quarterback of our
defense it's just a no excuses kid that
always shows up and gets it done in
spite of his handicap I would consider
him to have a physically handicapped I
would not consider him disabled because
he is more able than many of the players
we have on our team with both arms so I
go to second grade classroom and I just
help kids out with either in math and
reading or setting up their portfolio so
10 you will conductor 22 shines awesome
the kids love to have him in our
classroom they love to have him out on
the playground they look up to him know
he's a football player he's a basketball
player I had her Shawn second grade
there was one thing that Josh on told me
if he couldn't do and that was tie his
shoes and that was the only thing that
was pretty hard I didn't learn that's
like second grade but even then
like that's still good for me I remember
the first time notice he tied his shoes
they were tied he had did it when we try
to reach down tie his shoes he was like
not having it so he was gonna be okay
when he stepped out into school in the
world sha Shan is living his life the
only way he's ever known but let's be
real one arm or two he still gotta prove
himself
every day on the court hand off going
barber was legit but going pro is to
focus I hope someday that I could play
at the highest level of NBA or football
that's my ultimate goal
although out there ever since like last
football season I've just been looking
up to Chaconne Griffin he has what I
have amniotic band syndrome anything's
possible I guess like if he can do it
anyone can do it I can do it for me you
know playing basketball in the backyard
that was my passion you know when I
finished my homework me and my brother
went outside we would play until my mom
said it was time to come in and eat
dinner you know everyone has their own
story you know and you really don't know
where somebody's from until you
go visit them and see what it's like for
me it's just going to basically put a
smile on his face and let him know that
somebody will come to highway you know
and drive past all these cornfields and
give him the time I got next
you got some gang huh what's up boss
what's happening
nice to meet you man what's going on all
right
I seen the video you don't get an area
thing huh what you mean old now you shot
yeah what I was out here hoping you can
use your elbow
[Music]
get it come on got that Oh a lot smaller
on to kid I'm a lot smaller on 2k what
you mean by that
[Music]
I can't imagine well just not being able
to come back just like we're like behind
the back and I win this one from you
back in the day the Clippers ah so I was
playing basketball with dad and Chris
Paul pulled over and working with him on
dribbling like getting past the defender
and basically talked me through how to
get around people when they were trying
to defend my right side I appreciate
y'all having me out here man it's five
more exciting for me than it is y'all I
don't know about that seriously I know
like your story went viral and all that
stuff like that but to come out here and
see y'all I had playing like this and
this has got to be the coolest thing man
thank you so my own place man it's like
you gonna get your family my best oh I
have to go back to school but you know I
just met Chris Paul is like oh I'm like
okay you'll see yo what's up man I'm
here this is Carmelo Anthony thanks for
watching to meet more heroes go to be
real bleacher report.com
[Music]